si un truc qui vaut mieux éviter
si on veut pas tomber malade c'est de
compulser un dictionnaire médical parce
que là si vous êtes tant soit peu
impressionnable
c'était un tout petit peu émotif toi ce
que tu lis tu la vois des postes est pas
moins que des pour ma fille est la
cadette le lot qui nous attraper des
boutons et oui on n'a qu'à nous fait des
boutons le lot et quand je dis bouton je
pense plutôt du bon c'est même le gros
but gonds si c'est un fruit ça serait
plus près de la crise que la myrtille tu
vois pour ferry mal c'est dallas pote
peau enfin si mais vilaine déjà que bon
c'est ma fille mes objectifs voit quand
même pauvre cocotte peuvent le lot on
peut pas dire qu'elle soit vraiment nom
est sympathique et attachante mais alors
là ça lui fait des joues de tranches de
cake est gratos ans c'est dégueulasse
elle a les bras en duo de foie de veau
vachement appétissant alors on est allé
voir un dermatologue
hilary sculpté de partout temps en temps
je détourne et j'étudie ya eu des
gobelets dessus ils sont costauds des
types ça vaut la peine de faire des
études
enfin il a regardé quand même ce qui
déjà sympa de sa part et aux résultats
et ben il sait pas voilà il voit pas
bien il faut réfléchir aux adducteurs
mais c'est beaucoup comme je vous dois
voyez mon assistante 20 sacs 10 dont il
y en a qui veulent pas leur pognon enfin
on sait tous que c'est pas c'est pas le
plus à risque où je peux quoi je serai
jamais le dire c'est pas à l'hérésie ped
ça on est sûr c'est pas l'érythème parce
que l'érythème c'est plutôt fessiers et
un appart ou 7 dégoûtante
ça n'est pas non plus une quelconque ni
causes ni qwam qes ça serait peut-être
sans engagement d'aucune par une pirate
aux pilaire purulents
bini voilà on est content alors j'ai
regardé dans le dico cas kératoses
affection bénigne en effet se présente
en plus comme un état de la peau qu'une
maladie à part entière ça va au-delà
c'est pas une maladie c'est pour ça que
ça ce n'est pas transmission héréditaire
héréditaire probable rencontrer dès
l'enfance
ça c'est sa mère qui lui refiler des
[ __ ] chez nous dans ma famille
kératoses on n'a pas ça nous est demandé
à tout le monde à mes parents mon pépé a
même émis en a pas c'est pas nous
il ya deux c'est tout ça c'est
dégueulasse
évolution des buts le plus souvent dans
l'enfance
oui et peut subir une accentuation des
signes lors de la puberté
elle est encore petit yacht mais avait
été ce qu'ils de notre jeune fille vient
nous aider à lui trouver un fiancé ça on
pourra toujours mettre une annonce dans
des stations thermales y aura bien un
eczéma de passage qui sera intéressé cet
âge là c'est bien connu ça les démange
les petits bourgs à la vache chez la
femme fréquence d'une guérison spontanée
à l'âge mûr
de quoi je me plais à petit on vient de
fêter ses cinq ans en avril dernier à se
gratter la couenne jusqu'à sa ménopause
c'est les 40 premières années du temps
les plus durs
d'ici là pour son anniversaire on y
offrira les moufles ils ont rien prévu
sur l'euthanasie
l'édition bien enseignants vachement
encourageant rassurant je viens moi
quand je dis ça j'ai tout et puis on
écoute de tas de trucs la langue noire
géante pas à jean thériault définition
hyper profit des papilles filiforme de
la partie postérieure de la langue celle
ci devienne grises ou noires at à la
vache on est peu de chose
l'affection indolore ah ben ça fait pas
mal c'est déjà ça origine inconnue il
dans l'équipe fébrile soleil matin il a
la langue noir personne sait d'où ça
vient
on peut qu'il soit catholique pratiquant
et des communes ils passent pas
inaperçus les mecs
on agissait la communion c'est plus
comme avant tu as plus besoin de montrer
tant le curé et un petit chignon tu
trouves dans un coin en passant encore
de dieu autant aller à la boulangerie
tonnes chose rare du paf fret mais la
maison contre le risque de tomber sur un
compte du devis remarquer que tu as du
noir sur la norme
la langue noir à la vache si je me
doutais que ça existait des machins
pareil alors traitement de points ok
mais comme ça au moins c'est clair ça
c'est fort le type ia qui sait pas d'où
ça lui vient les apports pas au
nettoyage du nord allô docteur g la
langue noir et bien monsieur c'est votre
problème
les goûts et les couleurs moi je suis
marié avec une japonaise et j'en suis
également la langue au noir les saint
cyriens parce qu'on peut toujours su
séduisant pour donner le change mais y'a
des trucs dans ce bouquin cumin
testiculaire ça c'est pas mal non plus
s'observe à tout âge les formes maligne
sont parfois féminisant tu es peuvent
donner des tests biologiques de la
grossesse positif dire que lorsque
l'équipe non seulement ils sont tous
avec les baloches comme des paupiettes
mais en plus sur le nom speed et en
cloque j'espère pour lui et
l'accouchement sans douleur au type
je pense qu'au moins une stagiaire est
moche comme ça il faudra taper au lasso
je me mets à courir partout dans les
couleurs de lost ou encore serge blanco
avec une plume dans le cul ah bah moi
pas plus qu'on engueule métier à
l'horreur mais quel horaire mais comme
moi il faut tous ces médecins pour
supporter tout ça tous les jours ça je
me le demande souvent parce que si c'est
dans le livre il est gros et la planète
comme ça et c'est fait par des gens qui
savent donc ça arrive dans la vie tous
les jours comment ils font faut voir
moral surtout dans certains secteurs
le type qui se spécialise dans une
maladie qui se guérit pas
trois mois je pourrais pas
si je suis là je fait l'intéressant gens
racontent le dictionnaire médical mais
j'ai horreur de ce genre décoration
horaire aurait parce que il faut que je
vous souhaite un aveu mois rien que d'en
parler
la maladie ça me tue